welcome everybody back uh we're pleased
to have
jane gao from university of waterloo
talking to us about the rank of sports
random mattresses
please thank you andrew for the
introduction and thank you very much for
inviting me here for
for the talk so um i'm going to talk
about the brandon's plus
the rank of uh the rank of spots random
matrices
and yeah and also excuse me for the very
unprofessional look of my sites so this
is
a collaboration with ir codiagalan
argo ita rich mueller and robin
so i'm going to talk about three random
three models for random matrices
and just for this talk i'm just simply
going to refer them to
uh refer to them as simple models
flexible model version one and flexible
flexible mode flexible model version two
so for the simple model uh there are
three parameters and
um positive integer k um positive real
number d
and a q as a prime power and we are
going to use the
finite field with order q
okay so the model is quite simple as the
name suggests so it's
n by n m by n matrix
um and each row for each row you just
independently choose
k entries and for the other entries you
put zero and for those
k entries you choose
non-zero entries from fq with some
prescribed distribution and in fact
in the whole talk the distribution
doesn't really matter so for now we can
just assume it's uniformly distributed
and only um the only
uh thing that we really require here is
its
permutation invariant okay
um so that's the that's the model
um and for the flexible model
um we just changed the definition for d
and q and there's very various reasons
why we do this
like in the simple model um we do know
that
uh with high probability you will have
columns that are all zero
and there are also columns with a lot of
non-zero entries
um typically there exists a column that
the non-zero entries
like of all the roughly log n and for
some applications
you just don't really like this kind of
matrices for instance if you want
this matrix to to use such matrix for
constructing
low density parity check code you
probably want
there's no no 0 you don't have any
all zero columns because they don't play
any row
um so in order to control the the
profile of the degrees and the profile
of the number of non-zero entries
in each row we would like to specify the
distribution
and that's the row of the d and the k
here
so d and k are just independent random
variables satisfying certain constraints
they just try to bound to the tail such
that
the tail doesn't become grow too strong
and then you do want the support of d
and support of k to be
integers um and then i will just
generate
n iid copies uh according to the
distribution of d
and and m iid copies of k
and those d1 dn will use that to specify
the the number of
non-zero entries in every column
and case will be
the number of non-zero entries in each
row
and ideally i would like to set up in
the
situation that the expectation of d
times
n is roughly speaking the expectation of
the k times
m and that's just because i don't want
to the event
that the summation of all the non-entry
zeros in each columns and
and compare with the all the summations
in of the k
wouldn't be sorry this event that they
are equal wouldn't be
too small the probability of such events
wouldn't be too small
otherwise i couldn't really successfully
get um
to to to to create such event
okay so conditional on such event
then i'm just going to uniformly choose
choose my random matrix where the g
the row j has exactly kj non-zero
entries and the row i has
exactly di non-zero entries
and for the non-zero entry you choose a
random
non-zero element from this finite field
of q with some prescribed distribution
so any question about the model okay
so for v2 it's exactly the same the only
thing is
we don't want to restrict the field to
be finite field anymore you can actually
put any
general field here
okay um and uh here's the result for the
rank
of such random matrices so for a from
the simple
model we get the rank
of matrix a scaled by n
roughly speaking it can be expressed by
some function that depends on k
and d and i don't really want to
write down the function because it
probably doesn't really
matter so much here how how it looks
like
and it's just a simplified form from the
next slide
at the more general form so for the
flexible model where k and d are
prescribed
random variables you write down that
you can write down um the
probability distribution for for random
variable d
and i use d of x to denote this
generating function
and also the probability generating
function for k
is u is denoted by k of x
and then defining this v of alpha to be
roughly speaking some compositions of
those two functions d
and k here and also involving the
expected value of d
and expected value of k here and compose
them in a certain way
so the more general form is just that
the more general theorem just says that
the rank of a from this model more
flexible model
scaled by n is is
equal to this formula one minus
the supremum of this fee alpha where
alpha is some
real number between 0 and 1. so for the
simple model
this theorem covers the simple model so
for the simple model we know the degree
distributions
for d it's poisson and then k is just a
constant
it's always three so it's a polynomial
here for k and you
substitute those functions specific
functions d and k here and simplify d of
x
um and then you get to deduce the
formula that should be in the
universe the previous slide okay
so um so here's in this equation
um the upper bound actually was
um proved by lelach
like in 2013
and was conjectured to be equation also
in the same paper
and we just proved that the the lower
bound actually matches
the upper bound as well jane can answer
the question
yes uh sometimes like in coding theory
you like really care about the case of
the rank of a being full is it possible
that you can
uh get at this level of detail or yes
it's also only about
in fact if you really check what this
supreme is
um in many situations uh okay we may
i will talk about this maybe i'll tell a
little bit in a
bit future slides because it's apparent
about time
okay so in the even more flexible
uh model where you don't restrict the
field to be finite then
you actually get exactly the same
formula here
so so this result basically is
insensitive to
um to the to the order of the field
okay uh so here's just a brief review of
the literature we know before um
so the study of the of the linear
equations the
um i think in in 2002 when dubois and
the mandala
their papers for study of the actual
exothermic
the satisfiability threshold so um
so basically the first uh several papers
that i listed here are all for simple
models
and they progress in a way that you try
to make the model more
flexible and and cope with
more general parameters so the first
paper
cares about the special situation where
k equal to 3 and q equals to 2
and it was generalized to any q greater
than three but
constant and then it's generalized to
situation that the the order finite
field can be three and four
so this is the uh result that i talked
before so we generalize to any finite
field kill
finite field and
independently cooperative reason and
pectin
also proved the same similar result for
for the rank of
a the result is for
q equals to 2 though but it's
also oops
it works for every density so d can be
anything even though the previously
those results typically determines the
rank of a
at the density of the major square
it's before the matrix it's before the
matrix um
stop to become full row rank so let's
maybe speak this way you can gradually
add row one by one
and initially those row those rows that
you add will be
all independent and at some at the
specific value d star
um they start to become linearly
dependent
and though the first few papers over
here
analyze up to the point of v star and
these papers or
were able to get uh results that that
works for all the
and uh and for the flexible model i
didn't list
in in this in this page so
here i just want to quickly mention what
is the maxima
for for this function c of alpha
um there's some some uh conjecture of
where actually the maxima would appear
so you
take so this field buffer is a
continuous function
so you take the um you consider
the set of stable points and then just
let the row to be the maximum stable
points
and it's conjectured um and
based on the evidence of massive search
that in many cases this improvement of
this function
actually appears in the either at zero
or at
the row so either at the zero or at the
maximum stable
point and at some point it was
conjectured that it was always the case
and in fact it's not really true
um so so in the last
paper he already realized that there are
some constructions where
the supreme of alpha actually is
strictly away from
from the from the
maximum stable point and now we also
cook up some other example as well
okay um so the so now the question is
when like for what kind of instances you
do have the maximum
occurring at the zero of row and for
what
instances that this inequality becomes
um uh strict um
and this comes to really understand what
this role represents for and in fact
there's some very natural combinatorial
explanations or interpretations for this
parameter row
and that comes to the study of the two
core of this random matrix
so how do you get the tool of the random
matrix
you delete all the known sorry all the
zero columns and then you
delete a column that has exactly one
non-zero entry like this one and then
the corresponding
row and then repeatedly doing this so
the next round
this one because this row is deleted
there's exactly
only one non-zero entry here so you
delete that column and delete that row
so repeatedly doing this operation and
then you end up with
some matrix that
that every column has at least two
non-zero entries
and that we call the two core of the sum
matrix of this matrix
and then you can get a very trivial
upper bound for this rank of a
uh which is you just counting the number
ones
um that you you encountered in this
deletion process
and this deletion process basically just
corresponds to the gaussian elimination
and those ones are the pivoting entries
so they
count towards to the rank of a
and then and then the rank of a is
simply x
plus the rank of this two core which is
upper bounded by the minimum between
m star and n star
and then you just do some algebraic
manipulation then
the rank of a is totally determined by
basically
the size of m star and n and
the two core of such structure is well
studied in random graph theory and
not for this model but for more general
sorry more special
more unrestricted models but we can just
borrow the
arguments there and then prove some
results for this
for this a so work out the size of n
star and m star
and then you will get to this formula
and that's exactly
what this maximum of those two values
appearing naturally here
and uh and that's that holds with this
additional constraint that the second
derivative
of v at the row is negative and what it
really means that this is negative it
also has some
quite nice combinatorial interpretation
basically um if it if this if this
um second derivative is negative it
corresponds to the two chord that you
constructed
is very stable which means if you just
delete
a few rows and then you can keep doing
this deletion process
then deleting a few rows wouldn't
destroy the two cores significantly so
after a few more rounds of deletion you
you end up
with a two quarters just having a few
less number of rows and columns
and in the other or maybe the other way
to interpret
this is that this row corresponds to a
fixed point solution
in this belief propagation equation and
if if this derivative second derivative
is less than zero
it means this row is stable it's an
attractive fixed point
whereas in the other direction it is it
is the
derivative over there is greater than
one so it's not going to converge to
that point
so um so in that sense a non-stable 2
core doesn't really predict where the
maximum
point the where the maxima of the
of the function appears but if if if you
are happened in the case where
the 2 core is stable then typically the
rank of
a is predicted by what would be given by
this formula
okay and uh and then you can know that
um
easy calculation would actually show
that this this this rat this
um whole matrix itself is full
row rank in that case roughly speaking
okay um okay so i just want to quickly
say
um how to determine the rank of a
um how the proof works um
so the trouble to dealing with this this
random matrix is it's too restrictive
like
every um every row and
every column you specify the size um
specifically
so there's it's hard to perturb it
so in order to give some kind of
flexibility we delete
epsilon n rows from a and then create a
new matrix called a
epsilon and of course deleting just a
small fraction of
rows wouldn't change the rank
significantly
so it reduces to actually study the rank
of a
epsilon and using standard um
concentration inequalities we know that
the rank of a epsilon is concentrated
so it only remains to actually bound
the the rank of a epsilon
and to do that we look at the null space
of a epsilon which is
the set of x where a x equal to zero
and and that exactly equals to the log
of the number of basically the log of
the size of the non-space
taking the base of the log to bq
um that happens when q
is fi uh the the size of the finite
so if this happens this works for the
finite
um finite field
okay so so in this noun space there are
two
two properties that really helps with
the proof one is that we actually know
the marginal
of a random variable um
any random sorry a random a random
here is really random variable right so
a random
variable nodes so if you take a random
variable notes and think about
the um the space uh the space of the
of the solutions from the noun space
and then you look at the marginal
distribution um either
that the variable is uh it takes that
particular variable x i
takes value zero in the whole noun space
or it
um or it will have the uniform
distribution
in the finite field fq and that's just
by the property of linearity
and the second property that's useful is
the replica symmetry or
or what what's called long-range
correlation decay
so you take um this a
this matrix a and epsilon and um i
we use the i means favorite um pinging
strategy just ping
a bounded but sufficiently large number
of variables
into frozen variables so roughly
speaking you just
add a few rows where you put to one
in those corresponding columns
and that will turn the solution space
into symmetric space which means
if you just randomly pick k
k variables and look at their joint
distribution in this
in the solution space they form the
product rule
okay um so now how do we get to
estimate the expected value of log of z
scaled by n we just use this telescope
telescope
expansion and roughly speaking
this quantity expectation of log of z
is upper bounded by expectation of the
of the difference between consecutive
terms and then you can use the coupling
to couple those two
matrices together and then and i study
the log
of of this ratio and what only remains
to show is this
this expectation is founded by the
formula that we
we showed in the in the first few slides
um okay um
so so the trick here that that
it's probably a common trick for that i
don't know if maybe maybe
um everyone already knows um so you
you start you started from a and epsilon
and
how do you construct a and plus
one n plus one epsilon you basically
have to add a new column
a new new variable and then
according to the distribution of the
neighborhood of this variable you can
generate those
rows that are corresponding to the
columns here where those are non-zero
entries
but then you perturb the distribution
require the distribution for the number
of edges um
to too much and then to make the
distribution correct you have to delete
a few
a few rows okay so do it properly
instead you can actually delete those
those um rows according to the correct
distribution
and then that will be a prime and then
here you just
add those a column and then rows
and then the the a and epsilon would be
just adding those deleted
column sorry rows back and then you get
a an epsilon
and then we just compare the rank
between these two
two matrices and then the difference
between here and then you will get
basically get the uh the formula you get
right for instance if you want to um
check
how this quantity changes if you compare
this matrix and that matrix roughly
speaking it's the
it's just taking a uniformly random
solution and from this this matrix
and then look at the probability that
this
random this solution satisfy this set of
new
constraints and then you know the
distribution of those new rows
those new constraints so it's easy to
actually compute
this formula and then taking the
expectations
okay so the key features here is really
you have to
you look you work with this logarithm of
this set
because that is a set of solutions and
and then you ping
variables properly to make the solution
space metric
well but those all fail if if
if it's not finite field anymore because
you can't really define this log z
anymore it doesn't just make any sense
and then the whole
argument seems to fall apart for general
field
um and the trick here is that you
actually work on the rank or the nullity
um the nullity of the of the matrix
directly instead of
instead of working on the set of
solutions
um so i'm cheating a little bit here of
course you are still comparing with a
with that a prime thing but
uh to be a little um
lack of rigorous i just put a n plus 1
to be constructed by a
and adding a row a few rows and a and a
column
so how do we compute the difference
between their
novelty in expectation um
so something that's useful
is the following observation um you look
at this set of
rows here it's just a few constant
number of rows
and the sum of those rows sum of rows
and look at those columns they will have
a few columns that has
non-zero entries you um
you record there those indices so i
is the set of indices for those non-zero
columns in b
okay and then we say i is a relation for
this matrix a here
if you can do linear combination of the
rows a here such that
the non-zero entries would coincide
exactly with this i
so in that sense we say i is a relation
and it turns out that
if i is not a relation of a and
of this matrix then the nullity is
just can be easily computed the
difference of the nullity can be easily
computed as 1 minus the rank of this
new rows that you added here well in
other words those rows that you added
here are
independent of the rows in in this a
um so now the question is if
a a this matrix a and that's strong have
small
hat does have short relations the
answers they they do have some short
relations but they are not
bad ones so for instance you you may
have some frozen variables
and those frozen variables itself forms
a relation
um but the good thing is we know exactly
how many are there that
they are indexed they are um recorded by
this parameter alpha that's the
proportion of
frozen variables and then you may have
some
uh small relations exist but then the
pinning strategy works here
just as in the in the finite field k
field case exactly so if you just ping a
large enough number of variables you
kill all those short relations
but those pinning of variables doesn't
change the rank much
so once those short relations disappear
or become very sparse that
one you add those rows b bc here
it's hardly that i would hit any of
those those small relations
so they don't contribute much into the
final
expectation so therefore you really only
want to worry about the frozen variables
but those are easy to deal with by
gaussian
elimination you just take your ec
and look at those columns corresponding
to the frozen variables and then turn
those entries those columns into zero
columns
okay so so now the difference between
the novelty is simply
one minus the rank of b star c whereas
the rank of b star c
um you can you can easily compute using
this coupling scheme again
the only thing here is that you you
generate your your piece b
for instance this is just b um and now
with probability alpha for every
non-zero entry you're just turning it
into into into zero and i can compute
the rank of those new
new rows and and that completes
basically it's exactly the same
same formula same calculation it's just
writing the rank
in uh in a different way sorry i run
over time a bit
thank you
[Applause]
okay any questions yeah
could i ask a question so the um
the typical rank does not depend on the
field you're saying
that's right at least you know divided
by n and so on
but um sort of referring to ryan's
question i guess some of the the large
deviation probabilities do
depend on the field right just like the
the classic exercise of the probability
that
uh a non-sparse random matrix is is full
rank
right so i'm just curious about
since you have this concentration of
free energy
argument um
is it possible to actually
calculate large deviation rates for
having
significantly higher or significantly
lower rate
sorry rank higher or lower rank
i think i don't really get what do you
ask about
free energy um is what is free energy
in this case oh well what i it's a what
i i mean
the the free energy is the rank of the
null space right it's the
uh you have this sort of
you might not think of it as a
statistical physics style argument but
in some sense you know you're you're
saying well the
you know the number of solutions to the
see
the constraint satisfaction problem of
being in the null space
the log of that number of solutions is
the rank space
so i'm just curious whether it's
possible to sort of uh
anyway forget the free energy i'm just
saying that
is it possible to say anything about
the the exponentially small
probabilities
of having unusually high or
unusually low rank can you actually
calculate the those large deviation
rates as a function of the rank oh i see
you want to
to see the probability of deviating from
the typical rank
yeah maybe that's too much to ask but
i'm just curious
because i i would expect those rates to
depend
on the field even though the typical
rank does not
i guess it depends on the the random
matrices right
sorry maybe it's the same thing so it
might depends a little
okay my guess is it depends on the
structure of the two core
at least you know the the early
early proof techniques that i saw they
all reduce this
to the study of the two core and then
and then they show that the two core has
full
row rank and i think it probably has
something to do with if the if you if
you get a typical 2 call
or a very untypical 2 call
that's my guess and um
and i think you definitely so from
random graph theory
point of view you do get exponential uh
kind of
kind of um uh probability balance for
the points of the two chord
size is is evading from this typical
size
right i guess we we know that the two
core size has like gaussian fluctuations
maybe as long as that second derivative
is negative
um but i don't know if that immediately
tells you something about the
rank but if i i suspect that
maybe the rank does link to the
the size of the of the two core
especially
okay yeah yeah i couldn't really answer
directly but that's my guess
um if the two core is typical you
probably can show that
the the the rank is is full
or is predicted by you know the rank of
the two core plus
whatever you get outside people but if
you somehow get a
very small to call or something then you
obviously get
a rank that's very far from from the
typical value that we would prove here
and that probability you can you can
bounce
but i don't know if the other way is
also true if if the rank
of the matrix deviates from the typical
value does it actually
really is must be caused by an atypical
tupol i don't know
maybe i you answered this already and i
kind of missed it but i'll i'll ask um
anyway uh so in some you know settings
of the random variables d and k
like your formula will give that the the
typical rank is like
asymptotic to one times n but do you
know any conditions like when
i assure you that like the rank will be
literally full
and not just like full up to little of n
oh the full rank yes um uh
yeah it's very good it's very good
question in fact
um for all what we can prove like in a
simple model for instance
uh even though i said that it takes a
value
between um zero and one right oh sorry
zero in the row
in fact for the for the range
of the satisfiability so i put it in
here
yeah um
so those work where where you do
um um for d
less than the star you actually show
that they are full row rank
and that's all appearing at the place
that the
zero is the is the maximum so in some
sense if the
zero is the maxima it does um
there is such a correspondence here um
and then for more relaxed situation
it's um i think if if i have to give a
congestion
conjecture it's also the case that if
the maxima appears
at the zero and it's the unique maxima
then you should get the full row rank
even though we we do have some technical
difficulty to
prove it because because of the
you know if you want to prove guru rank
what's causing the problem here in the
proof is you you lose the flexibility by
deleting absolute m
right um and then if you don't delete
them
it's very hard to to to do this kind of
coupling
because of because it's very restricted
okay thank you but uh but i think i
think there's
uh i i at least personally i believe um
you can basically write um
the condition that if if the if the
maxima
is at the zero and it's a the unique one
then then i believe it's a
full program for such random matrices
okay
any more questions
you